guru what's up bro thanks for coming on
the in show with me
you got a Ross good morning to you good
morning to the Dennis Good Morning
America and happy fantasy football
drafting season this is the time when we
should be drafting when the third week
of the preseason is in the rearview
mirror now we're safe to draft we're not
too worried about what transpires this
evening by the way it's unbelievable
guru I had Tuesday night my buddy Dom my
buddy Luke they're texting me for
sleepers which tight end should I get I
mean I get people on Twitter the other
day I was at Hershey Park and a guy came
up to me and said oh yeah you're the
fantasy guy it's like what it's it's
unbelievable the popularity and it's
right now what is your number one and
don't just tell me value or whatever
what's your number one piece of advice
or strategy you're telling people that
have their fantasy draft tonight or this
weekend right now be skeptical and
cautious of the running backs this time
last year it was kind of hip trend to go
all all in on the wide receivers like
dudes with beards out there taking like
seven straight wide receivers to start
the draft the fantasy hipsters if you
will by the way the beard is the
Millennials mullet you heard it first
here on 20 years we're gonna look back
and and be critical of the beers as just
as I'm critical of my mullet that I had
in 1989 however the running backs are
dangerous and last year while the
hipsters out there were saying go with
seven straight wide receivers I was the
guy saying look don't forget about the
running backs back in 2014 they were
really really good now coming off a
great year for running backs people are
back in so I say be careful be more
oriented to the wide receivers now that
said I would like to get one good
running back at the first two rounds if
I if at all possible so I'll give you
the list of running backs I feel
comfortable with in terms of first or
second round
Le'Veon on bail David Johnson of course
Devon to Freeman Jay Ajayi
and Melvin Gordon those are the only
running backs that I feel good about in
terms of first or second round the
poster child for this is a LeSean McCoy
by the way last year I love McCoy loved
him he was a third round pick that was a
great vet be too hard to pass up and he
came through this
here is a first round pick no way bad
vibes there in Buffalo so be cautious of
most of these running backs early on
alright so guru in case you didn't hear
this morning shefter said that the more
people he talked to the more he hears
the more he believes there's a very real
chance that Zeke Elliott suspension gets
reduced if I am drafting tonight
thankfully I'm not but if I'm drafting
tonight before they come out with the
information over the weekend we assume
in terms of whether or not it's reduced
where am i drafting Zeke Elliott well no
way I'm taking them in the first we've
had them on the website
and we have a little bit of a company
think tank and we're all on the same
page we've actually had them slotted as
a third round pick because we're a
little bit worried about just the
instability of the whole situation but
now with this news and I know Adam very
well as you know and he's the best
information man in the business I feel
like I thought the six game suspension
was a bit much to begin with so I'm
feeling okay like maybe we're looking at
four hopefully he can just get it out of
the way early in the season and then
we're good to go you can draft darren
mcfadden so I will sign off on Ezekiel
Elliott as a second-round pick after the
top white outs that I like in that round
or off the board like after Amari Cooper
is drafted if you're looking at DeAndre
Hopkins or something like all Sean
Jeffrey oh I don't love I'm okay with
Ezekiel Elliott in that spot but you
must still get darren mcfadden just in
case well definitely at some point
McFadden is going to have value could be
early on in the season of course all
right so we're talking with the Guru
John Hansen you can check him out his
web sites amazing it's been around
forever fantasy guru dot-com he's all
over Sirius XM every morning the fantasy
Channel there and Sundays during the
season DirecTV fantasy zone
let's give me some value John at some of
these positions so I don't care wide
receiver tight end running backs just
give me some guys that you know so when
my buddies text me and say who are some
guys you're higher on then
others so I know who to draft tonight
well we'll go right back to the running
backs because I do think I'm cautious of
them but I feel like there's a buying
opportunity with a great rookie class I
will be honest I'm not I don't have a
great feel for Christian McCaffrey we
haven't seen much love the player
absolutely love them but we haven't seen
much with Cam Newton so I think he's a
little volatile Leonard fournette foot
is wearing me a little bit but I do love
Kareem hunt in Kansas City that's a
great third-round pick I'll take him
there all day long be very proactive
about it
I do like Dalvin cook as well third
round I think he's a complete back he's
going to do well the offense looks
pretty good the old line has been
stabilized a little bit and I love Joe
Mixon I know that Jeremy Hill is
starting but Joe Mixon is coming into
those games in the preseason very early
and he's clearly more talented than
Jeremy hill he can make guys miss you
can flex him from the formation so I
like that buying opportunity there for
those running backs at quarterback my
guy is Derek Carr it's all there for him
in year number four looks good old lines
good Marshawn looks like Marshawn Cooper
looks improved Crabtree's rock-solid I
like Jared cook another weapon added
this year by the way in cordarrelle
Patterson and here's perhaps the most
important point guys their defense is
going to stink so we've seen it this
summer they're making guys you know look
like superstars out there I mean Jared
Goff look good okay that's all we need
to say nothing David Carr though I
really love them and I talked to
somebody on the radio today who got him
in the 10th round which I thought was
just highway robbery
this guy is poised to have that true
breakout season I'm calling 37 touchdown
passes for Derek Carr also like Russell
Wilson as a value at the wide receiver
position you know it's very deep
I still like dog ball one more than most
I like I love Davante Adams as a third
fourth round pick Golden Tate is another
guy not not a sexy name neither as Larry
Fitzgerald but these guys are rock-solid
but a couple of exciting guys Griffin if
you will is what I call them Devante
Parker the light bulbs come on clearly
Jay Cutler loves to sling it to those
outside receivers with the big catching
ray
and that's him and he's a big chunk guy
tyree kill is going to get a boatload of
touches at the wide receiver position
for the Kansas City Chiefs by the way I
do love Ameer Abdullah as well as a Val
you know we can talk all day about
Willie Snead in the middle rounds
I still like Brandon Marshall and here's
I'll give you a name this guy I think
I'm gonna call it right now there are no
longer sleepers in fantasy football
there was a time when you could actually
have a guy in call him a legitimate
sleeper like Anquan Boldin's rookie year
I still get you know convulsions when I
think about it because I ranked a bit
like 59 that week and he had 200 yards
that was a sleeper those guys don't
exist anymore my call the sleeper wide
receiver of the year Chris Hogan in New
England love the fit year to with this
offense with Brady he's a lot better off
obviously the Edelman situation helps a
lot he can play the slot he's a good red
zone guy I'm really feeling it here this
year with mr. Chris Hogan and I liken
that same team by the way is a real deep
you know late-round guy loved me some
rexington Birkhead he's gigantic Danny
Woodhead that's what he is he can do
everything wrong you still didn't give
me a tight end dude give me a tight end
well look I'm going in on Eric Ebron and
I'll tell you exactly why number one you
bet on the pedigree there was a reason
he was a top-10 pick in the NFL Draft
he's very athletic his progress has been
slow but it's been progress it's been
incremental pretty good catch rate
Anquan Boldin left departed with eight
touchdowns and by the way the most
important point he was a top 12
performer in points per game in PPR
leagues last year and the dude scored
one touchdown you don't need any more
analysis than that the dude was top 12
he had one touchdown one more than me so
if you can get like five or six now
you're cooking with some gas with Eric
Ebron and by the way because he's been
down all preseason
he's basically a free pick like 120
picks into the draft guru you
really appreciate any time I get a
chance to talk with you thanks so much
DIRECTV fantasy zone check it out
all 17 weeks of the NFL season meet Kay
Adams and Michael Rapaport yes every
Sunday should be awesome you can catch
him on Sirius XM as well I try to get
them on my fantasy feast podcast as
often as I possibly can he is the Guru
John Hanson fantasy guru dot-com the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience